an Easter egg over 40 years in the
making Indiana Jones and a dial of
Destiny slipped in one reference that
made fans hurt almost everywhere
spoilers ahead in the conclusion as epic
as the dial of Destiny it was inevitable
that Dr Jones's last great adventure
will be filled with callbacks but
director James Mangold saves the best
hard tip for the end when we get a
reunion between Indy and the love he'd
thought he'd last well there's no time
at the present A and D after returning
from a trip of over 2 000 years in the
past Indy wakes up from his near fatal
gunshot wound back in his apartment with
no idea of how he got there turns out
after a Swift hit to the face from his
darling goddaughter Helena they along
with Teddy and the German pilot we never
see again escape the past where Indies
survived his injuries thanks to the
miracle of modern medicine there's still
one surprise left for the old time
traveler though minutes after waking up
he comes face to face with his estranged
wife Marianne played as always by Karen
Allen when the two are left to Hash it
out it isn't long before they kiss and
makeup exactly how they did 42 years
earlier for franchise fans it'll no
doubt get you in the fields here and
here and here proving that they still
have chemistry even after all these
years Mariette and Indy's moment is
perfect send-off the franchise needed
taking things full circle and showing
that even through grief these two are
meant for each other having both mourned
the loss of their son mutts in different
ways Marion reveals she still hurts from
what happened and the fact they've been
distant from one another in the Assa
where it doesn't hurt and he plants a
kiss everywhere she points it's a
heartfelt raw reverse all from a moment
that's not just a staple in the
franchise but a true piece of Cinema
history in Raiders of the Lost Ark
drawing the first adventure of Indiana
Jones Marion is sending to Indy's wounds
after being asked for it doesn't hurt
they finally show affection for each
other with Marion kissing Indy before he
drifts off George
Jones it's easily one of their best
moments together so seeing it replicated
in dial of Destiny hits just right
rounding things off with a loving
reunion and an almost heartfelt goodbye
to the great Adventurer he got a happy
ending he deserved but it's one that
finally sees him turning to emotional
injuries rather than the physical ones
who've seen him take after so many years
while the closing moment to the dial of
Destiny is a great little nod to in
these Origins it also ties everything in
a Charming bow as our worn down hero
gets a resolution he needs for most of
Indy's last great adventure there's an
added bit of regret to the standard
stubbornness we've always come to
anticipate with our beloved Explorer
this isn't just a story about the hero
pastors Prime but the regret of past
mistakes he fears he can never resolve
he even goes as far as to accept that
quite literally staying in the past is
the best course of action as opposed to
a present that he believes has no place
for him of course that's not the case
Wally's helpless to change the loss of
his son who died after joining the Army
against his father's wishes he can still
fix some things the style of Destiny he
gives indeed a chance to be a hero in a
different way and return to being the
loving husband to Marion that she's
needed even if he didn't originally have
it in him to be that particular hero the
world will always need Indiana Jones but
Marion needs him more and that's the
most important thing after all as Marion
said from the very beginning I damn
partner